is this like one for the books for them
to say we're not going to call we're not
going to turn these things over faking
the point and that is this worth it to
lose a timeout that you could use
probably on the last Drive maybe make
this we didn't need it what else yeah we
didn't need it cuz we won the game right
Peter I mean in my opinion that's insane
by Pete Carroll if that's why he did it
that is crazy Tampa Bay is driving to
tie the game with less than four minutes
to go you get the ball back as it turns
out with like a minute to go and and and
you and you basically admit that you did
this just to basically you know kind of
taunt the league or to say that the
league's policies on TAS interference
are wrong I mean I like Pete Carroll but
that is an absolutely crazy decision by
a head coach of an NFL team this whole
issue proves to me how emotional it is
and we already knew that but this is the
the crystallization of it it is an
emotional job it's an emotional game and
having the opportunity to throw that red
flag when you're pretty sure you're not
gonna win you should be pretty damn sure
you're not gonna win but you do it just
cuz it feels good right because you're
pissed off about something and you're
just gonna do it it's like letting an
f-bomb fly you probably shouldn't do it
but it makes you feel better even if you
know there's gonna be specially
depending upon where you say it there's
gonna be a little problem on the back
end so I these guys are gonna continue
to challenge pass interference calls and
Nan calls because they can't help
themselves John Gurdon has said he's
gonna keep doing it even though the
evidence is clear the only one that I
can remember in the past several weeks
being overturned was when somebody
grabbed T Y Hilton's left hand and
poured it in the other direction as the
ball was coming in and even then I was
surprised they overturned it because
they hadn't overturned other blatant
instances of pass interference they're
just not gonna do it Peter and I don't
know why these coaches are being so
stubborn I mean it just looked it up
Mike for
six seconds to go the Seahawks get the
ball at their 25-yard line in a 34 34
game the Seahawks have one timeout left
if you ask Pete Carroll at the time one
timeout left would you rather have two
timeouts right now would you rather have
two timeouts he'd be lying if he said no
so he made a decision emotionally that
really could have hurt his team that's
not what a good coach does yeah and
that's it this replay thing has made the
league more interesting but not in a
good way the sooner this season ends the
sooner they get rid of replay remove her
pass interference the better off we'll
all be
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports